what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
alright first things first I can't be
too loud because it's kind of late I'm
going to wake the neighbors up or
anything like that but as I said last
week at the end of our video on how to
kill some and Grundy that we were going
to switch things up this week and try a
little experiment now one thing I want
to let you guys know is that in no way
shape or form but anybody named Wade
and/or mokey have anything to do with
helping me flesh out this idea they
didn't think it up they didn't say hey
here's a video series idea that you
should probably consider you could try
it out see how it does and didn't tell
me that during the discord not at all I
thought this up entirely unlike if you
guys don't know the weekly pool has a
discord you'll find a link down in the
description it usually will just kind of
hang out I pop it in there comic story
and pops in there coming pop pops in
there we just kind of show up and talk
to you guys we love having conversations
where we talk about like comics and
solicitations and just general nonsense
and all kinds of good stuff but wait and
mokey were really the ones who thought
of this like we were sitting in there
one day and Wade was like hey man you
should do a video we're like that man
decides to kill humanity and so that's
what we're going to do we're going to
ask the question how could Batman kill
us now there's actually a couple reasons
why I chose Batman other than because of
the fact that he's a popular character
the first is because figuring out how
you would kill us is we want to take a
lot more thought than some of the more
powerful characters out there if we have
a character for example like Galactus
who could just show up and devoured an
entire planet that does not make for a
very interesting video it would be cool
but it doesn't make for a very
interesting video so we're going to go
with the complete opposite direction and
look at a character who has those
superpowers at all and figure out how
they could kill us now in order to
understand the second reason why I chose
Batman for today's video we have to
first lay the groundwork for the
parameters that we're going to be
operating under in this scenario so for
the purposes of this video we're going
to take Batman out of the context of the
DC Universe and we're actually going to
place him in our universe so we're going
to be asking the question if Batman were
real and he wanted to kill us how would
he do it and the reason why I wanted to
do this was because of the fact that in
the DC Universe eventually Superman and
the Justice League would just show up to
save the day so really kind of create a
weird situation but in the real world
there are no superheroes now let us jump
into this so let's start by doing a sort
of inventory of all the stuff that
Batman has
that he could use to kill us and we're
going to find out pretty quickly that he
has a really extensive list
first and foremost probably the most
formidable asset in Bruce Wayne's
Arsenal it's his bank account seven
minutes
never leave the cave without it Forbes
magazine is estimated Bruce Wayne to
have a net worth of nine point two
billion dollars making him the third
wealthiest superhero in all of comic
books behind the Black Panther and Tony
Stark
Forbes also estimates that Wayne
Enterprises brings in about thirty 1.3
billion dollars in annual revenues so
Bruce Wayne has some pretty deep pockets
and he's used his wealth to amass quite
an array of weapons and technology that
could cause some serious damage to
anyone that he wanted to take out and
I'm not just talking about gadgets in
his utility belt I mean sure the
batarangs and the grappling hooks and
the bat shark repellents are pretty cool
but if he decides to take us all out
Batman is not going to beat us up one by
one he's going to do something on a much
larger scale they can take out a bunch
of us at once that with that in mind we
know that man has his own aircrafts in
the form of the batwing which can travel
at near supersonic speeds and is also
undetectable to radar this in and of
itself would let Batman take out a ton
of people of course in the comics that
man is averse to killing so he hasn't
really outfitted his plane to be used
offensively but in our hypothetical
scenario here he has no such a version
so we could easily beat up the batwing
with high-tech weaponry and basically
carry out airstrikes against major
cities thereby killing a ton of people
in the process but is this really what
Batman would do well we have to keep in
mind that Batman is not only one of the
richest people in the world but he's
also one of the smartest so well they
could take the batwing up into the air
and rain fire down on us from the
heavens doing so would come with a fair
amount of risk to his own life as it
will be met with a pretty sizable
military response and while he does have
a pretty cool plane the United States
military has over 13,000 jets alone so
while Batman could do some damage in
this way it's almost certain that he'd
be shot down pretty quickly after
launching his initial attack now for
this reason I think it's far more likely
that Batman would utilize one of the
most important assets that he has the
Batcave while most people think it a bad
case simply as Batman's secret
underground lair it really functions as
an
higher crime lab surveillance system and
battle station for Batman's war on crime
but in our scenario instead of using it
to fight crimes Batman could just as
easily outfit the Batcave as a place to
plan out his killing spree
now since the location of the Batcave is
known to very few and his defenses are
nearly impenetrable even if someone did
find it I think the most likely scenario
is that Batman would find a way to take
us all out without ever leaving the
safety and security of his cage which
leads me to what I think is the key to
figuring out Batman's plan brother I
know for those of you guys who don't
know brother I was a satellite-based
artificial intelligence that Bruce Wayne
engineered so that he could surveil the
Justice League following the events of
identity crisis when he lost faith in
the team after learning that one of
their members named zahana had actually
wiped his memory and basically Batman
used by their eye to gather information
about all the metahumans on earth but as
we would later see brother I could also
be used for nefarious purposes over the
course of DC's publication history there
came a time when a man named Maxwell
Lord hacked into brother AI and
reprogrammed it with the intention of
eliminating superhumans by using its
surveillance technology to launch
strikes based on patterns that he had
observed now since we're dealing with a
Batman who's evil enough to want to kill
us all it's pretty reasonable to assume
that he could recreate the brother AI
technology and use it to target
strategic areas to achieve his goals
basically Batman would use brother AI to
target military bases law enforcement
agencies intelligence agency
headquarters airports weapon caches and
basically anything else that he deems
and obstacle to wiping us out now once
he does that without military and police
to protect us we're basically sitting
ducks and once that happens Batman can
pretty much take us out and whatever way
he thinks will be the most entertaining
and I mean literally any way he thinks
could Batman design a fleet of drones to
kill us in a series of strikes
absolutely could he wait until the
military was crippled and in carpet-bomb
it's out of existence yep could he hack
into the nuclear weapons stores and
cause a nuclear holocaust absolutely and
positively he could probably figure out
a way to survive the radiation as well
so really it's hard to pin down exactly
how Batman would kill us because he has
such a vast array of options on the
table which now that I think about it
how awesome of a villain would Bruce
Wayne make I mean there's some amazing
stories that could be written if DC ever
let a great
lighter turn Bruce Wayne into a
straight-up villain for an extended
period of time but anyway I figure we
draw our best to answer this question
hopefully we answered it well enough I
think we did a pretty good job trying to
figure out how it is that Batman would
kill us if he were real but if you guys
are new here to comment to explain make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the Robin course you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and if you guys have any
suggestions on other superheroes that
you would like to see kill us if they
were real respect some morbid requests
but if you guys have any other
superheroes you'd love to see carry out
this role of Batman they'll feel free to
post it down in the comment section and
I will catch you guys on it please
[Music]